another Zhu Ben
I only have 20 of those units Rainey
we've been playing the Pokemon go for
about a week now and the beta has ended
but I think one of the most fun aspects
as silly as it looks when you're trying
to catch pokemon it is seeing the spoken
in the real world how they pop up how
you're able to viscerally catch them
with real balls and like that's
something that's always been missing
from Pokemon game yeah I think that a
are aspect of it is one of the coolest
things so you could just be outside and
you'll see like a pin seer or Zubat sort
of pop up in the real world then you're
at Starbucks or something trying to not
look like an idiot doing this and I
think it's what you know that's what the
beta is really nailed for me is that
collection aspect of Pokemon so you know
you actually do have to move around like
your city to actually find different
Pokemon because they're not all in the
same place so it's great like it forced
me to actually get up get on a bus on a
train on a car move to different places
find all this new Pokemon it was really
exciting for me then what else did you
luck need to like about this well like
the developers previous game ingress
it's something that brings people
together and it does make you go out in
the real world and explore things and
look for new places to go and it does
capture that that aspect of what's fun
about Pokemon but it also misses that
most in temporal aspect which is playing
with other people like you and I were
both playing in the office and and I
know other people are out here in the
world playing but I never met anybody I
didn't know there's no way to interact
there's Jim battles but not a way for me
to to either battle with you or to join
together forces and try to catch
something yeah the chameleon aspect
seems to be really lacking right now and
you know I did try a couple of gym
battles but the mechanics of it weren't
really that great so you know it's one
of the key things that's letting me down
about this thing is you know the game
itself the moving around the world is
great but once you actually get into the
game like capturing Pokemon or trying to
win the gym battle it all feels really
loose like there's no real way for
example that I ever find that you know
what the ratio what the chances are of
actually catching a Pokemon sometimes
I'd throw 15 pokeballs at one thing and
it wouldn't catch sometimes I throw one
than it was there and the same with gym
battle you know trying to actually win a
gym battle seemed like it was just a
matter of a lot of pressing in the same
area on your own Europe on your phone
the whole time so if you didn't feel
like there was at any
skill involved in this thing and this is
a beta so it's very dense like I felt
like I ran into a lot of pokemons I saw
a lot of things that I was able to get
for free but how that's gonna work in
the real world I don't know monetization
is gonna be a big question yeah I don't
know whether it was to close beta and I
but it was super generous with coming
out with the in-game currency like
nearly every day I logged in there would
be some free like stuff and a professor
that you know meant that I never ran out
of pokeballs never ammeter potions never
run out of loose it was always easy for
me to actually keep trying to catch it
but you know if they crunch that down a
little bit I can see that maybe they're
gonna eventually push on the
monetization of that and you know force
you to actually buy pokeballs but it's
kind of hard to tell until the real
thing actually comes down yeah we've
only gone through the beta the closed
beta has completely ended now that
doesn't mean we won't get into an open
beta or maybe the full game is gonna
launch really soon I have a feeling
we're gonna learn more in July but we
won't know more until the actual game
launches so has it done enough do you
actually want to play it when it comes
out I'm gonna keep playing I'm gonna
keep going I think you definitely are
you seventy eighty Pokemon yeah so I was
actually really happy with this you know
like but the fact that he actually
caught me outside and you know I played
a lot with my son who's six years old
and he actually just wanted to walk in a
circle for about you know 15 minutes
because he just wanted to try and catch
different types of Pokemon so I think
for that target market if you love
Pokemon if you love collecting is
hitting a sweet spot got to catch them
all